mit dem bomber mama hast hast du nicht
heute geburtstag
services kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem
schippmann ellbogen anerkannte horn zu
einem neuen video und heute wieder mal
eine runde zuschauer überrascht format
was schon länger nicht mehr
was ist das zuschauer überrascht ist ein
format in dem ich auf meinem teamspeak
bin und zufällig zuschauer die da in
irgendwelchen channels rumgammeln
überrasche meisten zuschauer machen auch
nicht und die frage ob die bekommen
darunter markus mit mir zu spielen
ja dann würde ich sagen wir stoppen habt
ihr bock auf eine runde get down oder
sowas in der art
ja es so leute jetzt sind wir in der
runde und wir sind sehr zahlreich wie
viele sind gerade drin im channel 505
leute von uns wirklich können wir mal
wie es immer machen wir zuschauer auch
mal kurz durch gehen wie er heißt da
könnt euch kurz vorstellen wenn ihr es
machen wollt ansonsten einfach
überspringen
komisch ist oder peinlich fangen auf
obenan mit dem bomber was hast du dich
heute geburtstag gratuliere dir ja wie
stell dich mal vor
kurz der philipp heute vortrag wird
jahre alt richtig weiß was dann
kathrin i pad mir geht nicht jetzt
erzählen gut dann tobias kay stadt
runter jacobi station
ja und ich frei die von komisch waren
also wollte ich überhaupt noch
weitermachen oder lieber nicht richtig
dann würde ich sagen sind es gibt mir
das ist es wie im stuhlkreis man gibt
den ball herum
wie läuft's bei euch ist einer von euch
relax limo ghg
ist einer von euch markt 42 ist einer
von euch milo unterstrich nein aber es
casey stoner expert und kram pilz ist
auf jeden fall unsere leute jetzt ein
eis dann haben wir tatsächlich fünf
leute in der runde richtig stark aber
wir dürfen sich am ende nicht ihnen bin
auch noch da
wie bist du also jahre lodern haben wir
sogar ohne mich fünf leute insgesamt
sechs leute 17 stunden ein nein diesen
job will einfach aus der geschichte
gestrichen
ok jetzt müssen wir uns wohl auch
gegenseitig vernichten so schlecht sein
wird uns halt nur gegenseitig die
selección geht es gerne von mir so ich
habe ja immer weggerannt
fünf davon haben wir melo gehört auch
nicht zu uns nicht richtig krass bei
euch auch
jetzt kommt miro und ich komme aus dem
web raus
ok ich glaub jetzt von diesem weg für
ein bisschen zu lang
noch stehen die drei leben und der
kritik ganz zeit mein eigenes gesicht
die kann man leute richtig gut
angel provozieren muss ich sagen junge
dass bestimmte richtig ab wollte meine
effekt teilweise nicht mehr alles klar
jetzt stelle ich mir jetzt kicker wie
schaut es muss einfach klappen
zwar kommt ok ok damit sollen aber haben
ihren stern hermia sehr gut heißt keine
liegestütze es regeln und wir haben
immer noch drei leute wir also mit mir
haben drei leute aber richtig gut
geschlagen für das equipment
du hast eine leder jazz und den
goldwerten ich habe hier eine einzelne
axt also quasi in stein schwert und eine
voll ein
jetzt müssen nur noch gucken vorbei ist
noch drin also bei racing game stores
wird expert und relaxen sie hat wie es
noch trend zb aber gab ja ok dann lasst
mich kurz töten von ihnen als
geburtstagsgeschenk das nicht hin ich
gewinnen nachher man kann es natürlich
nicht wissen ich würde einfach sagen
dass ich so spiele als als würde ich
einfach ich gar nicht kenne es aber wie
sie drauf dann nehme alles mit was er
kriegen kann sagt walter der ich viele
leben bot alter schwede wieder noch
gefressen hat und es hier noch mal
erzählt mir meinen geschichten aus ihrem
leben leid
wie ist das gehäuse schützt also die
schiedsrichterprüfung
schiedsrichterprüfung liest dann okay
bestanden ja sehr nahes gratuliere danke
jetzt falls die bundesliga noch nicht
wissen ja ok aber ich geb dir ein halbes
jahr okay wenn es gut läuft ja schon
zwei drei monaten vielleicht nächste
woche auf den allerletzten besser kannst
du nicht reagan zumindest 5 erfolg
manchmal geben ich habe 26 apple also
schalten einfach das team zu haben
wir haben nicht gestimmt ok dann ja gut
weil wir uns jetzt gegenseitig mut geben
und ja ich hatte ja gut dann bist du
jetzt voll müssen fallen okay kommt auch
zwei leben alte okay gut im bogen
das ding gerissen danke fürs dabeisein
oder wollt ihr noch immer sagen
und noch mal alles gute im bob auf jeden
fall